you're the spiderman from youtube
what does it really take to be a
world-class superhero
tom holland or as many of you probably
know him spider-man
has become the face of the entire new
age avengers
but how did he get to this point exactly
from struggling with dyslexia bullying
and tumbling headfirst into acrobatics
we're showing you just how tom holland
rose to fame and the roller coaster ride
that came after
maybe we'll learn just how to become a
superhero ourselves
how do i explain this uh i have like a
sixth sense
the pizza tingle with his sandy brown
hair
impeccable english accent and cheeky
personality he's arguably one of the
more superior heroes to ever exist
but becoming more famous than tony stark
himself is no easy feat
in fact tom holland's life growing up
prepared him perfectly for the role of
peter parker
even if he didn't know it we are taking
it back to the good old 90s
to be more specific 1996 where his first
story
starts tom holland was born and raised
in london
alongside three other brothers
is it just us or does this sound like
the introduction to a retro disney
channel show
anyway believe it or not tom holland was
actually born right
into the entertainment industry his
parents might not be big hollywood names
but they stood their own
his father dominic holland is a comedian
and was the host of his own bbc radio
segment called the small world of
dominic holland
his mom nicola frost on the other hand
is a successful photographer in london
just like any of us would tom has been
taking his dad's experience and greatly
using it to his advantage
it's nice to have a dad who's been in
the industry for probably over 30 years
because he knows all the do's and don'ts
and the ins and outs
but despite being born to artistic
parents the reason tom
ever found that his talent slide with
the arts was because of his dyslexia
diagnosis
yeah you might be thinking what does
dyslexia have to do with him being
talented
but just stick with us and it'll all
make sense because of his struggle with
dyslexia
his parents enrolled him in a private
school for extra help and it was there
that he discovered dancing and acting
but it wasn't all hip-hop and improv
class from then on tom
actually struggled with bullies because
of his love for dance
but he just turned his head the other
way and carried on with what he loved
you couldn't hit me hard enough to stop
me from doing it and we're glad he did
because if he hadn't we wouldn't have
gotten this 2019 masterpiece of a lip
sync battle
or the rest of his career after
discovering dance at school he started
taking lessons at the nifty feet dance
school
where he was discovered by a billy
elliot choreographer
after some more training not just in
hip-hop but in classical ballet and acro
he landed a supporting role and then
eventually the lead role in billy elliot
the musical
although his role in the musical opened
major doors for him the spider-man suit
didn't quite fit yet
he was cast in his first major film the
impossible at just 16 years old
where he played a boy whose family was
caught in a major tsunami
after some smaller roles he landed a
major role in the 2015 film
in the heart of the sea alongside some
actors like chris hemsworth and brendan
gleeson
tom has said that after starring
alongside big named actors
he thought he had his acting career all
figured out with a yellow brick road
paved perfectly to hollywood
but the opposite actually happened he
struggled majorly with trying to land
other roles
i basically got into this rut where i
wasn't like taking auditions seriously
and i just thought
i'll get this job i'll get this job and
i didn't it was a bit of a punch to the
teeth
so his mom did what every other mother
would send him to carpentry school
but he wasn't there for very long before
he had the opportunity to audition for
his spot in the mcu
it was finally time for him to suit up
just like a lot of 90s babies tom
holland grew up
absolutely loving spider-man i always
wanted to play this character and when i
found out they were recasting the role i
rang up my agent
and he wasn't joking adorable then and
even more
adorable now he sent in a video acting
out two scenes for the casting directors
but also incorporated his past training
in acro and dance
to take the audition to the next level
he obviously got through to the final
stages
in total he revealed that the audition
process took a whole six months
that's dedication but his work for the
role didn't end there
some actors have to gain or lose weight
for a role others have to sit in the
makeup chair for hours
completely changing their appearance but
for tom holland
he prepared by going back to high school
how heroic
this was so tom could get a refresher on
what it was like to be an american teen
with an american accent and undercover
basically he was practicing being peter
parker without the suit
or webs but things were a little tricky
for tom when he found out he'd be going
back to a school for geniuses
the bronx school of science which is a
school for genius kids and believe me
everyone i am not known
like a true professional though he
powered through and managed to keep his
disguise for a full
three days his newfound fame didn't just
come with millions of fans across the
globe but with the added pressure that
tom holland completely didn't expect
it wasn't until i felt the pressure of
like is that person taking a picture of
me
he could never understand why
celebrities would get caught up in media
scandals until he took on the role of
spider-man
but luckily he could shout avengers
assemble and have a whole line of people
that could relate and help him through
it
well he hasn't really had any big
scandals come to light there were
intense rumors that he and co-star
zendaya were getting romantic off-screen
while sources came forward to claim that
they were in fact getting cozy with one
another
zendaya and tom lapped the rumors off on
social media and in interviews
even if zendaya did go out for dinner
with his parents luckily for us
they're still the best of friends and we
still get plenty of content with the two
of them on instagram
actually tom holland is reportedly in a
relationship with actress nadia parks
of course his role as spider-man has
landed him parts in a total of five
marvel movies so far
and yes there are more to come but
producers
and the world have discovered that tom
holland isn't the most trustworthy
person
in fact he's accidentally spoiled so
many secrets about films before their
release
that he isn't even given the full script
anymore who is least trustworthy when it
comes to the secrets
[Applause]
does everyone remember that time he
hilariously revealed the poster for
avengers infinity war on instagram live
youtube is full of compilations of
everything he said and honestly we're
surprised they even let him go on press
tours
despite his ability to be a little too
candid his role as spider-man has of
course led to some other pretty big
roles
he's done tons of voice acting over the
last few years like for the film
spies in disguise and doolittle
alongside tony stark himself
robert downey jr he even starred in the
hit disney pixar animation
onward i can't do it we're not gonna see
you dad
and while tom plays a heroic character
on screen his hero tendencies don't just
shut off when he isn't on camera
he and his family actually run their own
charity it's called the brothers trust
and it helps raise funds for other
non-profit charities that aren't as well
known
not to mention all the times he's suited
up to bring a little joy to kids that
may be going through some pretty tough
times
it may seem like tom has had a full
career in the span of just 10 years
but he's nowhere near finished so what's
next for tom holland you ask well of
course he's reprising his role as
spider-man for another sequel
not to mention it's a sequel that's
currently rumored to include both
past spider-man actors do you know what
that would mean
a movie that included tom holland toby
maguire and andrew garfield
also known as a dream come true he also
has other films currently in production
chaos walking cherry and uncharted
which we just got our first look at
we'll be seeing tom take the screen as
treasure hunter nathan drake we can't
wait to see what he unburies
isn't it freaky how tom holland's
backstory set him up to be the ideal
spider-man
if we've learned anything from his life
adventure it's that he truly is the
perfect peter parker
even if he can't keep a secret and being
just 24 years old there's no doubt we
can expect much more heroic endeavors
from him in the future
let us know what you're most excited to
see tom do next in the comment section
below
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a big thumbs
up
we love you three thousand